الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث تنظر
ما تعرف بلجنه الافراج المبكره التابعه
لمصلحه السجون الاسرائيليه صباح اليوم في
طلب الافراج المبكر عن الاسير وليد دقه في
اعقاب تدهور حالات صحيه ونقله الى قسم
العنايه المركزه في مستشفى اسافر جنوب تل
ابيب وقد اعتدى متظاهرون اسرائيليون على
عائله الاسير وللدقه وعدد من الدعمين لهم
امام سجن الرمله وكانت اللجنه قد اجلت
الاسبوع الماضي قرارها بينما اعلنت
النيابه العامه الاسرائيليه معارضتها
للافراج عن الاسير دقه رغم حالته الحرجه
بسبب اصابته بنوع نادر من امراض السرطان
ويقبع الاسير دقه في سجون الاحتلال منذ 38
عاما وقد اطلقت عائلته والاسرى في سجن
نفحه وجهات حقوقيه حمله للافراج عنه
وانقاذ حياته
معنى الان من امام سجن الرملي مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري كنا نتابع معك منذ
ساعات الصباح لهذه الجلسه التي يتم من
خلالها النظر في قرار الابل افراج المبكر
ان كنت تسمعين لنجوان يبدو انها تتعرض
اذا نجوان نتحدث اذا عن هذه الجلسه والتي
تزامنت مع اعتداء انا اسمعك ومواجهات اذا
مع مستوطنين قاموا بالاعتداء على عائله
دقه ما تفاصيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم مياده نحن هنا وما زالت حاله توتر
عاليه مع وصول عائله وبعض من المناصرين
للاسير وليد دقه اعداد كبيره من
المستوطنين والاسرائيليين الذين وصلوا الى
هنا وبداوا يتهجمون ويعتدون على عائله
وليد دقه تحديدا على زوجته وطفلته ميلاد
مضطرها الى ترك الموقع قبل قليل يقومون
طيله الوقت
بالهتاف ضد الفلسطينيين
يطلقون
المصطلحات والكلمات النبيه يصفون الجميع
هنا بالمخربين ويقولون انهم انهم يتمنون
لهم الموت جميعا بالسرطان هذا يحدث
بالتزامن مع الجلسه المنعقده هنا في سجن
الرملي للجنه ما تعرف بلجنه الافراجات
المبكر
لبحث مطلب بالافراج المبكر عن الاسير وليد
دقه نظرا لحالته الصحيه الحرجه وليد شو خص
بمرض نادر من امراض السرطان قبل بضعه اشهر
وفي الاسابيع الاخيره تدهورت حالته الصحيه
ونقل الى العنايه المكثفه في احدى
المستشفيات لكن هناك حاله من الاهمال
الطبي ايضا لان الوضع الحرج الذي يعاني
منه يتطلب عنايه فائقه لكن مع ذلك ورغم
انهاء وليد لمحكوميته
ب 37 عاما عندما تم الحكم على وليد تم
اصدار حكم بحقه للمؤبد وتم تحديد ذلك ب 37
عاما لكن قبل فتره تم اضافه عامين اخرين
على محكوميته وهو حاليا يقضي هذين العامين
اي انه يقضي 38 عاما في الاسر ورغم كل هذه
الفتره ورغم انتهاء المحكوميه
التي حددت له في البدايه الا ان هؤلاء
الاسرائيليين واعداد كبيره ايضا من
المسؤولين السياسيين يقومون بالتحريض في
الاسابيع الاخيره ضد امكانيه الافراج
المبكر عنه وليد بل ان مضمون الجلسه في
الاسبوع الماضي واليوم يبحث ايضا في هل
هذه اللجنه مخوله للبحث بالافراد بالافراج
عن وليد وذلك نظرا لمطالبه من وزير الامن
القومي المتطرف بن كبير بعدم السماح حتى
لهذه اللجنه بالبحث بامكانيه الافراج
المبكر عنه يطلبون نقل هذه اللجنه للجنه
اخرى تتابع
المحكومين بالاثر المؤبد رغم ان وليد
حاليا يقضي محكوميه ليست ضمن ما يعرف في
القوانين الاسرائيليه بالاسرى الامنيين
وليس وليست محكوميه
بالمؤبد بل هي تهمه توصف بانها جنائيه
وبالعاده يتم الحكم على من يقومون
بادخال هواتف مقاله للاسرى بالحكم عليهم
بفتره قصيره جدا ربما لايام او لبضعه اشهر
فقط لكن
هؤلاء المستوطنين نعم
نعم ان كنت قد سمعتك جيدا بالفعل منذ تولي
تمار بن كبير منصب وزير الامن القومي وهو
المنصب المتعلق بالشرطه الاسرائيليه ورغمه
كل ما يعانيها الاسرى اجمالا في سجون
الاحتلال الا انه فرض العديد من الخطوات
والاجراءات الانتقاميه
للامعان في معاناه الاسرى اكثر فاكثر
والان هو يتدخل شخصيا ايضا في منع حتى هذه
اللجنه المعروفه بلجنه الافراجات المبكر
وهي وفق القوانين الاسرائيليه تتيح
الافراج المبكر عن الاسرى لعده اسباب منها
حاله المرض لكن يعني هنا عندما نقول افراج
مبكر عن وليد نحن لا نتحدث عن سنوات وليد
من المفترض ان ينهي محكوميته الثانيه
العام المقبل ولكن مع ذلك ورغم انه قضى كل
هذه السنوات 38 عاما في الاسر ورغم بهذا
المرض النادر من السرطان وحالته الحرجه
جدا الا ان هناك تحريض ومطالبات بعدم
الافراج عنه نتحدث عن احد الاسرى عفوا اذا
يقومون بالقاء بعض الامور علينا اذا
نحن نتحدث عن احد الاسرى البارزين جدا في
الحركه الاسيره من اسرى داخل الفلسطيني
اسر عام 1906
وهو معروف بكتاباته انتج العديد من الكتب
والمقالات خلال سنوات اسره احد المقالات
البارزه له كان بعنوان الزمن الموازي
الموازي تحدث فيه عن علاقه الاسير بالوقت
وكيف يمر الوقت على الاسرى مياده اشكرك من
امام سجن الرملي مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري وارجو ان تاخذي مكانا بعيدا عن هؤلاء
المستوطنين الذين يبدوا عني فينا بالفعل
في ردود فعلهم اشكرك جزيل الشكر